okay so the topic of this presentation
is going to be the genetic inheritance
pattern known as sex-linked inheritance
so let's go ahead and get started all
right well let's first look at how is
sex determined in the first place here
we have a karyotype and if you recall
karyotype is a picture of a person's
chromosomes and like the notes say a
person's sex or a person's gender is
determined by genes that are found on
the X and the y chromosome this is a
karyotype of a woman that's why you only
see two X chromosomes where chromosome
23 is located or look at a male
karyotype in just a moment but women you
only have the xx chromosome combination
and so because you have the xx
chromosome combination in all of your
eggs cells no matter what there's going
to be an X chromosome you're not going
to find women you're not going to have
egg cells with a Y chromosome in it
women do not possess Y chromosomes so
women no matter what your egg cells are
going to have an X chromosome in them
it's not like that for guys though let's
look at guys next here's a pair a
picture of a male karyotype and you can
see males we have two different
chromosome twenty threes we have an X
chromosome that you see flashing right
now so males when we produce sperm cells
50% of our sperm cells will contain an X
chromosome and the other 50% of our
sperm cells will contain a Y chromosome
so it depends on the sperm cell that
fertilizes the egg if a sperm cell with
a Y chromosome fertilizes the egg the
baby is going to be a male if a sperm
cell with an X fertilizes the egg the
baby is going to be a female
so mathematically I want to prove to you
that there is a 50/50 chance of a child
being a born a boy or a girl if we use
the sex chromosomes like a punnett
square
I just put the XX female sex chromosomes
on top the XY male chromosomes on the
side if we treat a punnett square if we
treat the x and y chromosomes like like
we see in the punnett square and then we
fill in the punnett square you can
mathematically see there is a 2 out of 4
chance that a person will be born with
the xx chromosome combination that would
be a girl there's a 2 out of 4 chance
that a person would be born with an X Y
chromosome combination that would be a
boy so there you go 50/50 chance of a
child being born a boy or a girl
okay now I want to get into what are sex
linked disorders and like the notes say
they are inherited disorders inherited
conditions that are usually found on the
X chromosome yes there are some sex
linked disorders that are found on the Y
chromosome this video however is not
going to discuss those this video is
going to focus on chromosome disorders
found on the X chromosome because
they're just more prevalent they're just
more common one thing I want to mention
is that sex linked disorders are usually
recessive again yes there are some that
are dominant this video is not going to
focus on dominant sex length disorders
because they're fairly rare notice the
key that just popped up in the bottom
right hand corner I have an X with a
capital H the reason for that means the
X because again we're focusing on the X
chromosome the capital H means that
there is a healthy dominant gene on that
X chromosome the X with the lowercase H
the X means chromosome 23 the X
chromosome the lowercase H means that
the gene the on the X chromosome is
recessive
remember lower case means recessive so
watch this when we focus on a woman's
chromosomes remember women have two X
chromosomes well there's a few different
combinations that a woman might inherit
she might inherit two x's with capital
H's if that's the case she's gonna
obviously be healthy if she only has the
capital H's on her X chromosomes capital
H according to our key means healthy she
might inherit one of each one capital H
and one of her X chromosomes and a
lowercase H on her other X chromosome if
that's the case she's still going to be
healthy because health is dominant one
thing I want to mention is that this
woman would be considered a carrier
she's a carrier because she carries the
gene for these disorders on one of her X
chromosomes and then there's the third
possible combination and this is how a
woman can have the disease it's rare but
it happens a woman needs to inherit not
one x chromosome with the lowercase H
gene on it but also two two X
chromosomes each of them with the
lowercase H end
when we focus our attention to males
males we have the X Y chromosome
combination males are a bit easier we
either have the X with a capital H if
that's the case we're healthy or we have
the X with the lowercase H and if that's
the case we're going to have the disease
you might be asked asking yourself how
come you didn't put anything on the Y
chromosome how come there's no H's on
the Y chromosome because again these
these gene disorders are typically found
on the X chromosome so yes guys we do
have a y chromosome that doesn't really
provide us any backup so we're really
only focusing our attention on the X
chromosome I want to mention that sex
linked disorders are much more common in
males they're very rare in women and I
hope you see why women it's twice as
unlikely for you to have these disorders
in order for a woman to have a sex
linked disorder she has to inherit not
one X chromosome with the lowercase H
but two twice as unlikely to happen
women you have a backup X chromosome
guys we're not so lucky we only have one
X chromosome if our only X chromosome
has a disorder we're going to have the
disorder
focus on quickly on a few examples of
sex-linked disorders there's a why
here's an X chromosome blinking let's
zoom on into an X chromosome and when we
zoom on into an X chromosome for
instance the gene that caught that
causes colorblindness colorblindness is
a sex linked disorder it almost always
affects men very rarely our women
colorblind and you can see the gene is
located near the bottom of the X
chromosome also near the bottom of the X
chromosome is the gene that causes
hemophilia again hemophiliacs are almost
always male it's very rare for a woman
to be a hemophiliac it the gene that
causes hemophilia is also located near
the bottom of the X chromosome well
located near the top of the X chromosome
is a gene that causes a form of muscular
dystrophy here and again this type of
muscular dystrophy because it's sex
linked it's almost always going to
affect males and and again I hope you
remember why males we don't have a
backup X chromosome so if our only X
chromosome has a defect we're going to
have a defect women you do have a backup
X chromosome so if one of your X
chromosomes has a defect your other X
chromosome is most likely fine and
therefore you'll be fine
so I just mentioned colorblindness is an
example of a sex-linked disorder well
here's a neat little picture on top you
can see the spectrum the color spectrum
that a normal person with with normal
vision has about 92% of the population
has normal color color vision then you
start going down the list and you can
see the percentage of people that have a
certain type of colorblindness and what
the color spectrum looks like to them
this is kind of neat when we look at a
rainbow flag let's look at that quick so
here's an example of a rainbow flag and
what a normal person can see however if
you have a colorblindness and I hope I
don't pronounce this wrong called
deuteron Apia about 2.7 percent of the
population has this form of
colorblindness this is what the rainbow
flag looks like to them
again let's go back to our normal
rainbow flag there is another type of
colorblindness called protanopia it
doesn't affect the very large percent of
the population only 0.5 9% of the
population but this is what that same
rainbow flag looks like to them one more
one more example if we go back to our
normal rainbow flag and we look at what
a type of colorblindness called try to
not be again a very small percent of the
population is affected by this type of
colorblindness but you can see what that
same rainbow flag looks like to them and
one of the myths is that people who are
colorblind see in black and white and
that's not true they still see in color
it's as their colors are shifted a bit
here's a little quick thing that you can
do others there's all kinds of examples
of colorblind tests and so here's a
colorblind test there's a number inside
of the picture can you see the number 53
in the picture how about
there's a number inside of that picture
can you see the number 12
how about this one there's a number
inside that picture can you see the
number six how about this one
there is a number now is a little harder
I thought a number inside of this
picture can you see the number 74 and my
last one for you
so here's the last one can you see
inside of this the number six by the way
if you can't see one of the numbers it
doesn't mean you're colorblind there's a
whole series of color blind tests these
are just a few from that series okay so
if we were in class I would give you
guys a minute to try to answer this
these questions right here so pause the
video pause the video and try to work
out this very quick family Jen and Adam
try to work out this real quick family
try to do a Punnett square and answer
these questions I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one so first of all
the story tells me that Jen is a healthy
carrier of hemophilia so I'm going to
put Jen on the outside of the punnett
square like I just did and it says Adam
has no history of hemophilia in his
family so he's got to be healthy he's
got no history of it so there you go i
labelled adam in the outside of the
punnett square well now like we've done
with punnett squares I simply just fill
in the punnett squares there's the top
right there's the bottom left there's
the bottom right now that I filled in
the punnett squares you know it might be
helpful to label label inside of the
punnett square the phenotype top-left I
have the phenotype of a healthy girl the
XX means it's a girl the to capital h's
means that she has normal she's not a
hemophiliac she's healthy the top right
hand corner I have an XY combination
that means the boy the capital H tells
me that the boy is healthy does not have
haemophilia the bottom left I know it's
a girl because she has two X chromosomes
and I know the girls healthy because she
has a capital H but she also has a
lowercase H that makes her a carrier
she's healthy but she carries the gene
for hemophilia on one of her X
chromosomes and finally the lower right
hand square it's a boy I know that
because the x and y combination but this
boy is a hemophiliac because of the
lowercase H this boy has an X chromosome
with the gene for hemophilia on it so
now that I've done the punnett square
question a what is the probability of
having a daughter with haemophilia
I hope you can see the answer is zero
there are no squares that will give me a
girl with haemophilia question B the
chances of having a child who's a
carrier I hope you see that there's a
25% chance of that 1 out of 4 is 25%
question see a child with haemophilia I
hope you also see the answer is 25% you
can see that there's that haemophilia
boy in the lower right hand corner
question D this one might be confusing
at first you might think the answer is
75% because you can see 3 out of 4
squares are healthy but that's not the
answer the answer is actually 9 out of
16 or 56% let me show you why what's the
chances of having not one healthy child
if it was one healthy child the answer
would be 3 out of 4 but the question
saying what's the chance of having 2
healthy child
well here's two healthy children pretend
the child on the left was born in 2010
pretend the child on the right was born
in 2013 in 2010 that first child had a 3
out of 4 chance of being healthy just
like the punnett square above shows me
couple years go by mom and dad want to
have a second child
in 2013 what's the ads that child is
healthy again 3 out of 4 you can see
that in the punnett square above 3
squares out of 4 are healthy but when
you combine the ads you have to multiply
the 2 together we're not asking what's
the chances of one child being healthy
we're asking what were the ads that both
of them combined would be healthy so 3
times 3 in the numerator is 9 4 times 4
and then I'm the denominator is 16 so
there's how you got your answer
okay here's a harder story problem this
one's harder because I'm going to ask
you to draw a pedigree and also do a
Punnett square it says haemophilia is a
sex-linked disorder Kelly does not have
haemophilia even though her mother did
Jim who's Kelly's husband is a
hemophiliac their first child Barry is
healthy but their other child rachel is
a hemophiliac
draw a pedigree for this family and a
punnett square for Jim and Kelly if
you're doing this at home
pause the video I'm going to start going
over this in three two one so the first
thing I'm going to do is draw a circle
for Kelly remember circle are women
notice how Kelly is not colored in if a
circle or square is not colored in that
tells me that they're healthy the story
says that Kelly is Kelly does not have
hemophilia but it also says her mother
did so notice I have a circle for
Kelly's mother and I colored in that
circle remember in my previous video on
pedigrees any time you see a circle or
square colored in that tells you that
the person has the disease the story
says Kelly's mother is a hemophiliac so
I colored her in Kelly is married to a
man named Jim so a square means a male
circle means a female so a square for
Jim but notice how I colored in Jim
because the story says that Jim is a
hemophiliac they have a child they have
two children their first child Barry I
think the name Barry implies a male's
name so there's a square for Barry
notice Barry's Square is not colored in
because the story says their first child
Barry is healthy but the story also says
they have a girl by the name of Rachel a
circle for Rachel and notice I colored
in Rachel because the story says Rachel
is a hemophiliac so now that I've drawn
the pedigree I want to try to label the
genotype of everyone I'm going to start
with Kelly's mother she's a woman so I'm
going to use the X and X chromosome
combination and because the mother
Kelly's mother has the disease she has
to be lowercase H lowercase H that's the
only combination for a woman to have the
disease even though it's rare you can
see it can happen next I'm going to go
to Jim Jim is a male he's a square right
there so I'm going to give him the X and
Y chromosome coming
but because his Square is colored in I'm
going to give him the lowercase H that's
the only way for him to have the disease
moving on to Rachel it's a girl X and X
is the chromosome combination and again
just like Kelly's mother Rachel has to
be a Hema field has to be colored in so
she's a hemophiliac she has to have the
two lowercase H's so even though this is
rare for women to be hemophiliacs it can
happen now I want to shift my attention
to Barry Barry is a square I'm going to
give them an x and y combination but
notice how the X has a capital H Barry
is not colored in Barry's healthy I'm
gonna give him the capital age for
healthy when it comes to Kelly I know
she's healthy the story says she does
not have hemophilia so I'm going to give
her an X with one capital H for now in a
moment I'm going to figure out her other
X but I know for now that she's healthy
so when it comes to Kelly's other X
chromosome is it a capital H or is it a
lowercase H there's two ways I can
figure this out look at Kelly's mother
Kelly's mother only has X's with
lowercase H's therefore Kelly's mother
is going to pass on an X with a
lowercase H there's another way you can
figure out Kelly look at Kelly's
daughter Rachel Rachel has two x's with
lowercase H's one of those had to come
from dad
Jim the other one had to come from mom
Kelly well now let's shift our attention
to drawing a punnett square
okay now that we're done with a pedigree
let's focus on a punnett square I know
there's the X and the y for Jim and I
know there's the X and the X for Kelly I
know Jim and Kelly now so I can do a
Punnett square for them top left I'm
going to fill in the punnett square top
right I'm going to fill in the punnett
square bottom left and bottom right well
just like I did in the previous example
I think it's really helpful to label the
phenotype inside the punnett square in
the top left I see X and X for a girl
and I see a capital H even though
there's only one capital H I know she's
healthy you can see I labeled this top
left squares being a carrier because she
carries the lowercase H top right of the
punnett square x and y that implies a
boy the capital H means that boy is
going to be healthy bottom left of the
punnett square X and X means it's a girl
but there's only lowercase H's therefore
the girl's going to be a hemophiliac
bottom right of the punnett square x and
y that means it's a boy but the
lowercase H means that boy is going to
be a hemophiliac so now we answer
questions ABC and D question a what's
the probability of getting a healthy son
from the punnett square you can see that
there's a 1 out of 4 chance 25% of
having a boy who's healthy question B
what's the chances of having a healthy
daughter you can also see a 1 out of 4
chance even though that square I just
highlighted is a carrier she's still
healthy she does not have the disease
emo philia she's just a carrier question
C what's the chance of having a child
with hemophilia that would be 50/50
child implies boy or girl I just
highlighted the two squares one of them
on the left is a girl one of them on the
right is a boy 2 out of 4 is a 50%
answer question D what's the chances of
a child being a carrier I hope you can
see there's the 1 out of 4 again for 25%
so there's a great example of a Punnett
square and a pedigree done together
okay so here's the final task here we
have a pedigree involving 14 people I
want you to try to figure out the
genotype for as many people as you can
there's a hint in the lower left hand
corner of the 14 people you're going to
be able to determine 13 I'm not going to
tell you who's the one person that's
unknown try to solve this pause the
video I'm going to start going over the
answers in 3 2 1
so the first thing you might want to try
is focus your attention on the male's I
think the male's are easy the males are
either going to be X capital H and a Y
or X lowercase H and a Y so male number
5 male number 13 male number 14 they
have to be the X with the lowercase H
because they're colored in they have the
disease all the other males have to be
the opposite have to be the X with a
capital H number one number three and
number seven and number eight and number
ten and number 11 they're not colored in
that tells me they're healthy and if
they're healthy they have to be X with
the capital H so look at that we already
got I think about eight or nine people
figured out well now we need to shift
our attention to the women the women are
a bit harder
so when we shift our attention to the
women there's three possible
combinations all of these women are one
of these three now I can cross off the X
lowercase H X lowercase H H none of the
women are that combination and I know
that because none of the women are
colored in gray all of the women are
left white that means that they're
healthy I just have to figure out what
version of healthy
are they homozygous dominant or are they
heterozygous well you know I'm going to
go ahead and start giving every woman
and one X with a capital H every woman's
healthy so I can at least get started by
giving her one X with a capital H I know
they're healthy now I have to figure out
what is their second X chromosome so
first of all let's look at woman number
two and let's look at the boy that she
had person number five is going to be
the clue to figuring out woman number
two person number five is a boy and he
has a Y chromosome that he must have
inherited from his father boys get their
Y chromosomes from their father
therefore the X chromosome had to come
from the mother so there we have one of
our persons has now been discovered
person number two must have passed an X
with a lowercase H two boy number five
so person number two has to be
heterozygous well let's see if we can
use that pattern to solve other people
next person I want to focus on is person
number 13 person number 13 is a boy and
he got that Y chromosome from his father
so if person 13 got the Y chromosome
from the father then person 13 must have
gotten that X chromosome from the mother
that X chromosome has a lowercase H it
had to come from woman number 6 woman
number 6 must have given person 13 an X
with a lowercase H we've now solved
another woman so there you go we've
solved two women and we have a couple
more we have three more women to go the
next person I want you to focus your
attention on is person number 14 it's a
boy person 14 s male and the pattern
that we saw previously is going to work
for us this person number 14 is a boy
therefore he must have gotten that Y
chromosome from his father if he got the
Y chromosome from the father that he
must have got then he must have gotten
his X chromosome from his mother his
mother happens to be woman number 9 so
you can see the boy in number 14 has an
X with the lowercase H and now we know
who it came from it came from woman
number 9 so I now know that woman number
9 is heterozygous even though the story
never told me that well who can we focus
on next
okay so next I'd like you to focus on
woman number nine well woman number nine
has an X chromosome with the capital H
she must have received that from her dad
her dad is man number three
clearly male man number three her dad
passed his X chromosome if male number
three passed the Y chromosome then
person nine wouldn't be a girl person
nine would be a boy because person nine
is a girl I know that she received the X
chromosome from her dad so she got the X
with the capital H from the dad that
means she got the other X chromosome
with the lowercase H from her mother so
person number nine has an X with the
lowercase H she didn't get it from the
dad because dad doesn't have a lowercase
H clearly woman number nine got the X
chromosome with the lowercase H from her
mother so there we go
we've just figured out woman number four
woman number four has to be heterozygous
so when we focus on the last person
person number 12 woman number 12
she has an X chromosome she must have
received that X chromosome from her
father clearly person 3 the father never
gave her a y chromosome or she'd be a
boy so she got that X chromosome from
the father the problem is what did the
mother pass did the mother pass the X
with the capital H or did the mother
pass the X with the lowercase H we just
don't know I know she got an X
chromosome from the mother I just don't
know which one so there's the one person
that we just can't figure out so I hope
that helped okay if you're in my biology
class go ahead and pause the video and
try to answer these questions if you're
in my class bring your answers on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
check them for accuracy good luck